hey y'all we are about to try three of
the tastiest fried chicken dishes in
beautiful sunny Los Angeles we each have
our own pigs I'm clearly gonna win
you're absolutely not
oh wow there's no way I'm gonna let them
sign it out cuz we know in the end I'm
gonna win
you might want to say soon so sweet
[Music]
the tastiest fried chicken I've ever had
is that sweet chick in Los Angeles and
it's the chicken and waffles I'm from
the south so basically that means I have
eaten a lot of fried chicken
this particular fried chicken reminds me
of how my grandmother used to make it
it's juicy tender it's nice and crispy
there's a lot of herbs and a lot of
flavors that are going on when you're
eating it everything is kind of a mess
on your plate and then for the maple
syrup on your waffle and just so happens
but a little bit of that maple syrup
it's on that chicken and let me tell you
something I actually can't tell you
anything because that's how good it is
my name is John Seymour I'm the founder
of sweet chick and today we're gonna
show you how to make our fried chicken
and waffles all right John what are we
gonna do here what we got to do first is
we're gonna make our dredge so our
dredge starts with all-purpose flour so
we have some paprika
I am thyme black pepper salt baking
powder cornstarch so cornstarch is gonna
give it a little extra kind of crunch
we're gonna whisk all that together what
we have over here is our raw chicken but
not only is this our raw chicken this is
our brined chicken you're not brining
your chicken you're just not doing your
chicken right one of the key ingredients
that we use a sweet trick is our sweet
tea brine so now Nick your turn to get
dirty make some fried chicken got it I'm
a little nervous
all right so into the dredge okay take
off that excess
Oh in the buttermilk give it a bath in
that buttermilk and then back in there
pull into the fryer whoa look at that is
it it yes
you got you guys yeah so depending on
the piece it's gonna be like 13 to 15
minutes we're putting into the oil is
about 350 degrees
so we're known for chicken and waffles
the sweet chick and we do a bunch of
varieties one of my favorites hopefully
your favorite Apple Cinnamon waffle
so we have our apples we were already
kind of cooked down we want to make sure
everybody gets a little bit of Apple
right one of the things about our batter
that makes it so special is how we whip
our egg whites so we whip our egg whites
to a stiff peak and that's what's gonna
give it that like airy texture boom
we're gonna make that cook oh man smell
that apple cinnamon oh yeah go you're
not getting cheated yet there we go
I'll let you do it so that is a powdered
sugar and cinnamon that we only use for
this specific walking we're ready to eat
[Music]
mmm that's Griffin he's got a nice
coating and comes right off the bone
there's this a tiniest bit of heat comes
up underneath your super crispy
super juicy right off the back this is
like this is how you execute fried
chicken it's all right on let's try a
little waffle action I'm gonna go honey
about around the first I'm gonna go the
herb butter that's like it's the happy
accent you're supposed to yeah I feel
like for me I'm more of a savory kind of
girl
but having that like butter on the sweet
it's like the perfect balance there and
then you had the chicken and it's pretty
right you know boyfriend and you walk
out of here with Sam smiling
or girlfriend all right it's okay I
don't have a girlfriend all right sweet
chick it was pretty good I'm not gonna
lie I enjoyed it a lot but it's not
night market and they are the tastiest
chicken in LA
what makes Thai foods so great is the
way it brings together these different
flavors sweet spicy sour salty and you
get that in these wings when you bite
into them the first thing that you get
you get that glaze immediately the taste
hits your mouth while you're biting
through that wing it's kind of sticky
but then you get to the crispy chicken
skin and then into the juicy tender meat
imagine the best buffalo wings you've
ever had and then turn them completely
on their head it's like a slap in the
face in the best way possible i'm
christian memory i'm the chef and owner
of night market restaurants here in l.a
and today i'm going to show you how to
make the party wings first it starts
with brining the wings and fish sauce
and white pepper white pepper is
something we use a lot in our food i
think it really brings a nice kind of
aromatic quality so that's just fish
sauce white pepper dilute it with a
little bit of water you know we're doing
like hundred pounds of this or more at a
time it's perfect yeah it sits for a
while but for our purposes we'll just
let it sit for a minute after this we're
gonna take the wings out and we're gonna
coat it in this fantastic Thai product
called fodeez it's essentially like a
seasoned flour like these I just like a
little bit decoded yeah so it's it's
it's about the chicken skin right
exactly
now we're just gonna drop these into the
what roughly temperature we can hear 350
yeah like standard frying in terms of
cook time we're looking at about five
minutes but really when I think of
Croton when we talk about it in the
kitchens yeah it's always in terms of
how it looks right we're gonna heat up
our sauce so this sauce is a reduction
of coconut sugar vinegar garlic a couple
different types of chili we're gonna
toss in the wings right now yep really
getting that sugar in there starting to
caramelize a little bit toss in our
onions the night market party wings oh
my goodness oh my god it's sweet its
savory sweet salty tangy mmm in the
words of Nick Hillary I'm dead
chow I am dead too we are both day
outside of this crispy crackly skin it's
amazing I don't even know where to start
you're getting that sweetness that
caramelized coconut sugar is in there
the intense umami of the fish sauce it's
working it's a symphony working at the
same time and it has a little kick which
is nice right but it's not it's not
overpowering yes there's no doubt that
the wings a night market are great but
that said the tastiest fried chicken in
Los Angeles and actually in the whole
world is at Howlin rays no doubt about
it
Helen Ray's does Nashville hot chicken
and you can get mild but they go all the
way up to the howlloween it has made
grown men burst into tears he's
literally crying my mouth is still on
fire you know it's gonna be hot and then
you bite in and it's got this crispy
exterior it's juicy and then the heat
comes it's this weird thing of wanting
to cry and also want anymore
my name is Johnny zone I'm the owner
here at Holland raised in Chinatown
we're gonna be making a hot chicken
Sando today so we're gonna be doing some
Nashville hot chicken here so we got a
chicken breast here we got our dry and
this this has a mix of a lot of
different like you know spices and sea
we're going to enter our wet right here
type of buttermilk we're gonna go back
into our dry and so it's just a quick
dip yeah it's super simple
so from this stage we're ready to drop
it into the fryer oh it's from like it
3:10 to 360 ish or depending on it if
you want a juicier chicken or coaster
your outside what's your preferred
juicier crispier I like him to be both
so we're gonna head over and toast some
buns
this is a little secret tip and it's
very specifically designed for this
purpose and that's it and then the
butter that we use is a blue rub butter
I'll advertise that one that one's
really go so this is literally like a
French clarified butter yeah very
expensive we're gonna just get it nice
and toasty so now we're gonna take our
chicken and we're gonna dip it in what I
like to call a little bit of love and
then we're gonna adjust it to the heat
level that's ordered so we're gonna make
this one medium right here how Lin and
the extra hot and stuff like that they
have their own little stickers so we
know because they have different peppers
in different levels how many people
order the hell 10%
Wow we have to supply gloves to them
next we're gonna take our Mississippi
comeback sauce kinda like it's it's a
tangy version of a ranch it's got a
little hot sauce in it it is a secret
Bay this is my wife's recipe actually so
we're gonna load that on our bun
okay chickens going down so I'm goes the
slaw on top of here pickles are gonna go
right on the top one I feel like
sandwiches are always about layers
that's what my wife taught me but
honestly I wouldn't be where I'm at if
it wasn't for a hundred percent alright
then we're gonna wrap this so if you
were there cuts around would go like
this and pass it's you and then you
proceed to consume the same I would
precede it to do it immediately we're
training her on how to pass the sound
out all right so you got two hands two
minutes and then you pass and you scare
them in the eyes you stare at them and
if they laugh you still stare at them
there it is
that's customers wait wait how do you
feel I think we just have to do it
this is when the show gets boring cuz
this is so good I don't have anything to
say I've been tough I've known I have no
word Johnny
John what are you doing
I literally just gave me a hug the other
sandwich is this a breast how do you get
a chicken breast to be this juicy the
crazy thing is there's so much hype it's
like people are talking about this like
this is the best chicken you can get and
so my expectation would not have been
higher and completely mental I loved
that spice the medium is the perfect I
got room to go up I'll say that room you
wanna you guys go extra high that all
you have oh my god
I can't feel my tongue you're crying
are they tears of joy it's really good
has made them cry my mouth is still on
fire Alexis Mike I'm gonna go ahead and
speak for Nick here I'm sorry thank you
you were like Helena is it's a
transformative experience I mean out of
body out of mind out of soul I mean you
cry you laugh to cry we honestly did
also I think I think it's worth saying
like the chicken we had at the other two
restaurants was so good no no the idea
that Collin raised could be that much
better that there's no question it's
just like it's crazy it's so good it's
the best it's worth going to Los Angeles
from just for that chick
[Applause]
[Music]